good thursday everybody the cbs comedy
the unicorn it's about a group of
friends who
helped their buddy wade get back out in
the dating world after the loss of his
wife
well i got a chance to chat with two of
the stars rob cordrey and
michaela watkins and i had a feeling
yeah anything goes with these two right
from the start
don't you love this zoom thing it's like
we get to really see the real
you at home a little more relaxed
yeah this is how relaxed i am by the way
let's see oh look at you you got your
pjs on i
love it what do you michaela
are those your favorite sweats are those
your zoom sweats
these are my these are my floral pajamas
these are my zoom in pants zooming pants
we've all got them
well rob and michaela play wade's
married friends forrest and delia
and in tonight's episode they try to
rekindle a spark in the relationship
by playing tennis together but their
competitive sides take over
i know couples that try to go out and
golf and that never really
goes well so what happens here
yeah you know tennis i guess was was
something that
uh they used to play when they first
started dating
much to forrest chagrin because
uh to hear him say adelia was terrible
and
he was on his college tennis team and he
let her win
he drops the ruse and and they they go
at each other
and uh and it's um it ends up
uh having a positive effect but not
maybe the one
you thought yeah not in the way that you
thought
well we'll have to wait and see how it
all turns out rob and michaela say they
love the story lines of real life
with a little comedy thrown in but it's
not slapstick and they
really liked my suggestion for a future
episode
well would you guys do me a favor would
you take a a a plot idea
of the friend circle on a road trip to
vegas would you take that back to the
writers and see if they'll buy that oh
yes please wouldn't that be fun yeah
i would love it my god yes oh boris
closing all nighter
honestly i would give anything to go to
vegas right now we would love to have
you
well i guess they're going to take it
back and let's see what happens guys you
can catch the unicorn every thursday
night at 9 30
right here on channel 8. they were so
fun to talk to alex
they seem fun and they need to hire you
as a guest producer
sherry i'd be happy to yeah or at least
put them
get on the road trip with them yeah
absolutely all right